Yesterday, I learned that the chemo was supposed to start tomorrow.
The carbonyl plant is unavailable due to a nationwide shortage.
Instead, they're switching leads to something called doxyl.
Would a switch in chemo like this also require you to adjust
whether the supplements, no, I'd say no, I wouldn't do that.
Question popped in there, if I test IGF1, what is a good test?
What is a good result for cancer patients?
So IGF1 has a range.
So you can follow the range that the lab gives you.
I can't remember it under 270 or something like that.
I have had neck cancer with tumors and symptoms all on my left side.
Oh, that's not a really good question.
So if you want to reform, you're like that question.